[Música]
les doy la bienvenida un nuevo episodio
de boleto de vuelta que en esta ocasión
nos lleva a sierra leona país que vivió
durante más de 10 años una de las
guerras civiles más violentas y brutales
que haya conocido el continente africano
todo empezó en marzo de 1991 tras un
ataque en los rebeldes del frente unido
revolucionario en el este de sierra
leona cerca a la frontera con liberia
para derrocar al gobierno de turno en
ese momento el general presidente joseph
me envió sus tropas para frenar la
rebelión marcando el inicio de una
violencia inimaginable de golpes de
estado en serie con la participación de
algunas potencias extranjeras
el presidente de liberia de entonces
charles taylor sería condenado tiempo
después por crímenes de guerra y
crímenes contra la humanidad cometidos
en sierra leona pues se estima que o
entre 50.000 y 200.000 muertos de este
oscuro capítulo también se conocen las
migraciones mutilaciones y los miles de
niños secuestrados y obligados a
combatir en una guerra que también
estaban en juego los flamantes que eran
vendidos a cambio de armas el conflicto
y las atrocidades sólo acabarían hasta
2002 20 años después sobrevivientes los
que cometieron barbarie y los que lo
perdieron todo intenta recuperar su vida
es una guerra sangrienta en un país que
vive aún sumido por la corrupción
si de coroma no había regresado a este
pueblo desde hacía 28 años
fue en 1993 el 23 de diciembre
en ese momento la guerra ardía desde
hacía tres años
aún era adolescente
y rebelde en el frente unido
revolucionario el grupo armado que
originó la guerra civil que devastó a
sierra leona era un combate de primera
línea para el ruf
dirigía al grupo para conducirlo al
ataque sorpresa
a los pasos de checkpoint aquí y allá
primero un simple soldado se vuelve
rápidamente combatiente y guardaespaldas
personal de podéis aunque el jefe de la
rebelión es o 23 de diciembre de 1993
estaba en primera línea durante el
ataque a este pueblo normal
lo recordaré siempre ese tipo de éxito
en un momento en el que estábamos en
dificultad este pueblo fue el lugar en
el que obtuvimos nuestra primera gran
victoria frente a las embestidas
militares de joyas agachándose de coroma
y sus tropas atacaron normó fama azul
zac y cámara estaba aquí
habitante del pueblo hacía parte de los
numerosos civiles atrapados por esta ley
lo recuerdo
un día de 1993 hacia las 4 de la mañana
los rebeldes ingresaron al pueblo todos
estábamos en nuestras casas y la mayoría
de nosotros decidió permanecer encerrada
tomé a mis hijos junto a mí y nos
escondimos pero vinieron a buscarnos
nos reunieron bajo el quiosco principal
del pueblo todos juntos
y ahí vi a mi tío ensangrentado y esa
mujer muerta habían dado de baja ese día
entendí que la guerra había llegado aquí
esa noche unos sesenta civiles fueron
masacrados por civil y sus obras
en una iglesia o al inicial
es muy tarde para repensar el pasado no
se puede regresar
hoy en día son personas que volvieron a
ser normales son granjeros sostienen
comercios hay que avanzar
[Música]
en los apuntes de esta abogada reposan
miles de testimonios de víctimas y de
víctimas pero también todo un trabajo de
reflexión para tratar de sanar los
traumatismos después de la guerra se
puso en marcha una comisión por la paz y
la reconciliación
jasmine youtube services fue una de las
instigadoras de
la comisión verdad y reconciliación es
importante para que la verdad se conozca
así ya se sepa
cuando sabremos que nos hemos
reconciliado
y los mecanismos de transición siempre
son imperfectos la reconciliación quiere
decir que cada ciudadano asume su
responsabilidad
viajaban al día
mucha gente nos dijo no no necesitamos
saber lo que ocurrió
debemos concentrarnos en el futuro todos
estamos traumatizados estaba esa
dificultad de poner a los autores en
frente a sus responsabilidades y hacerle
frente a las atrocidades durante la
guerra pero creo que con el paso del
tiempo con conversaciones la población
empezó a entender el valor del trabajo
campal
desde 2002 varias ongs han hecho
dialogar a las poblaciones apoyándose en
una tradición el fan bulldog una especie
de discusión familiar basada en la
confusión y el culto al perdón pero más
allá de la resiliencia como
reconstruirse muchos sobrevivieron a las
masacres a las privaciones a las
torturas perpetradas por los de frenas
víctimas invisibles que siguen llevando
los estigmas de esta guerra
nos encontramos en sus 'fans' bay
durante la guerra dos millones de
personas huyeron de los combates para
refugiarse en freetown esta villa
miseria se volvió el punto de llegada
para numerosas familias nunca más se
fueron veinte años más tarde 27 mil
personas aún viven aquí en condiciones
desastrosas
antes de la guerra la comunidad que
vivía aquí no estaban sobre población
como ahora
durante y después de la guerra vimos
llegar a mucha gente
y actualmente la mayoría aún no cuenta
con recursos para instalarse de manera
conveniente de schuster ya su distintas
viviendas son muy costosas o permanecen
aquí y esta zona está expuesta a muchos
desastres o es difícil sobrevivir para
ellos quedan expuestos a otros problemas
tales como la droga la prostitución en
cuanto a las mujeres
hace parte de las consecuencias de la
guerra y de todos los desastres que
deben afrontar
sierra leona es golpeada con frecuencia
por los desastres la guerra y le vuela
pero también numerosas catástrofes
naturales
infortunios en cadena que se suman a una
pobreza endémica saidou abdalá es un
antiguo soldado del ejército regular hoy
en día se siente olvida
tomás a
yo combatí por este país como
sierraleonés
tengo 52 años actualmente me de donde
vivo
y mire dónde estoy con mis hijos
laurel y vio así vivo
y soy alguien que combatió por este país
un tifón y con mire aún tengo ropa del
ejército porque
why do pingüé lyon
como podemos ser uno de los países más
ricos del mundo y ser tan pobres
entonces porque hay que volver a la
guerra
desde la guerra por supuesto que las
cosas mejoraron pero necesitamos más
para ayudar a la gente
le inquieta que esto pueda provocar
nuevas violencias
avn un récord yo sentí que se nota
creo que nos volveremos a ello nos
volvimos gente responsable necesitamos
avanzar ya no queremos guerra la vimos
la recordamos no queremos regresar a eso
no queremos regresar a eso los combates
ya todo eso tan solo pensar en ello no
nunca más
[Música]
para estar seguros de que los rencores
no hagan resurgir nuevas violencias el
tribunal especial residual pone a
disposición del público los vestigios de
la guerra civil en esta sala imágenes de
cuerpos mutilados talismanes recuperados
en los teatros de las masacres restos
humanos es la primera vez que cid y el
antiguo rebelde entra aquí recuerdos que
suscitan más nostalgia que
arrepentimientos en él
porque se ríe
estas cosas el tipo de cosas que veo
aquí me trae recuerdos
[Música]
como que por ejemplo
si esta vestimenta tradicional
considerábamos que eran protecciones
para cuando íbamos a luchar
station
lo hacíamos todos
el rubí las fuerzas regulares yo conocí
a la sexy singular
yo conocía la existencia de este museo
pero nunca había tenido oportunidad de
verlo con mis propios ojos
es por ello que río
todo esto es pasado pero está bien de
todas formas y en todo caso no me pone
mal ver esto de nuevo
h
está lo que el público quiere ver pero
también todos los documentos
confidenciales los informes y los
testimonios considerados como muy
violentos para el gran público son
conservados en estos archivos por el
coordinador del tribunal patrick para
tomar
con frecuencia cuando olvidamos el
pasado se cometen los mismos errores
entonces garantizamos que este lugar
exista
y que la sensibilización y el trabajo de
memoria continúe para no olvidar las
atrocidades que ocurrieron en nuestro
país
no quiero hablar sobre el gobierno
actual del país
es un poco tensionante pero de lo que se
informada ha cambiado y la corrupción y
el mal gobierno eran cosas que ya
existían antes de la guerra
y hoy en día vemos como los rencores
relacionados es un tema de preocupación
es por ello que como institución tenemos
la responsabilidad de continuar con la
prevención a lo largo del país y
recordarle a la población que las
señales están y que debemos poner
cuidado
frente a esta inercia algunos decidieron
comprometerse durante mucho tiempo
cerrado el espacio político sierraleonés
cuenta ahora con nueve partidos
reconocimientos entre ellos el r usp
estamos en la parte este de freetown
aquí él instaló su oficina política
desde el 2011
el grupo rebelde ahora entidad mónica
desea mejorar su imagen y ganar
credibilidad
la gente el gobierno sigue viendo al ruf
como un partido malo
entonces exigiendo mejor a nuestros
consejeros y a nuestros miembros en el
parlamento la gente entenderá mejor la
ideología de nuestro partido
y ahí tendremos una reputación más
positiva
liza co es el portavoz del partido
el roof es un partido revolucionario y
seguirá siéndolo
el problema es que los políticos y la
comunidad internacional siguen con su
propaganda contra nosotros
y nos hacen pasar por gente
irresponsable
bajo el pretexto de que cometimos
atrocidades durante la guerra
pero son cosas del pasado
desde el 2018 sierra leona es gobernado
por julius maravillo el país se
desarrolla sin embargo un habitante de
cada dos sigue viviendo bajo el umbral
de pobreza el trabajo informal es la
norma saqueo de recursos también
diamante el oro y la bauxita exportados
por las empresas extranjeras que aportan
ínfimos beneficios al país sierra leona
le apuesta entonces a otra de sus
riquezas sus playas las más bellas del
continente africano y no para ninguna es
un hombre de negocios tiene 25 millones
de dólares
creo que el país logró pasar a otra cosa
ocurrió aquí es pasado ya no ocurre
no hay incidentes desde el final de la
guerra no ha habido golpes de estado
este tipo de cosas entonces creo que es
un país que se volvió
aquí sólo la élite puede permitirse una
tarde frente al mar con bebidas y
almuerzo es el esquema clásico del
desarrollo que genera más diferencia
entre la clase dominante y la clase
pobre sierra leona no es la excepción la
broma seria del asunto social estos
proyectos le preocupan a una nueva
generación
urbanización galopante deforestación
polución
hawai aquí es una joven militante por la
protección del medio ambiente con tan
sólo 19 años se involucra en operaciones
de sensibilización plantando árboles
plantaremos los árboles que tenemos para
la escuela así los alumnos pueden
entender y darse cuenta de la
importancia de plantar árboles
y cómo ello puede proteger el medio
ambiente en el futuro
debemos reflexionar sobre cómo encontrar
un equilibrio entre proteger nuestro
medio ambiente y desarrollar nuestro
país desde mi punto de vista es posible
actualmente tenemos una joven generación
lista para nuevos desafíos relacionados
con el medio ambiente y el género la
igualdad vemos jóvenes capaces de
proponer nuevos métodos de gobierno
entonces creo que trabajando juntos
podemos sanar los traumatismos de la
posguerra nos repusimos de la guerra y
trabajamos juntos para construir el
futuro
esta es sin duda la riqueza más
importante de sierra leona una juventud
consciente de los dilemas de la
reconstrucción pero comprometida con
inventar un mejor futuro
[Música]
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta sierra leona recuerde
que si quiere ver este y otros capítulos
en español puede visitar nuestra página
web france24 puntocom
[Música]